New York in the heart of Manhattan it's
home to the new york international auto
show the second big motor show to take
place on US soil this year
he said yeah I knew [ __ ] oh yeah admire
from Porsche says it's a trade fair
between 800,000 and a million people
visited the show last year and just as
many were expected this year he says
here on the East Coast that makes a real
state porsche presented the newest
addition to its lineup here the 2016
Boxster Spyder it's powered by a 3.8
liter 6-cylinder direct-injection engine
and unusually for a convertible in
boasts a top speed of 290 kilometers an
hour though it can only reach that speed
with the roof shut due to the
aerodynamics Toyota had one of the
biggest stands at the car show the
Japanese automaker presented its entire
product range one of the most eagerly
awaited new models was the rav4 hybrid
well the rav4 has become one of our most
important vehicles here in the US the
segment is growing faster than any
segment in the industry here and has
been for the last couple years the rav4
hybrid runs on a gasoline engine and an
electric motor Toyota hopes it will set
new standards when it comes to energy
efficiency meanwhile lexus presented the
next generation of its successful RX
almost 3 million of the luxury
crossovers have been sold to date the
trunk of the new model opens by holding
your hand over the Lexus logo Lexus
expects to bring the model to market by
the end of the year Volkswagens new Gulf
all track made its us debut in New York
this trend setting station wagon could
really make a splash in the American
market as VW's Heights jakub no sir
explains there goes he says the Gulf all
track fills the gap between big SUVs and
sedans and offers people the chance to
go off-road as well as on road no
diminish catchment so we'll unload the
offered so far one of the highlights of
the show in New York was the
presentation of the world car of the
year awards 75 automotive journalists
from 25 countries voted for their
favorites in five categories the votes
were then counted by a major independent
auditing firm
how does have the magnets Fiat fine
amatis is impressed by the fact that the
results aren't known beforehand kpmg
tallies up the votes and the results are
a surprise to everyone here this year
the most coveted trophy for world car of
the year 2015 went to the Mercedes
c-class it's a Mercedes in a traditional
segment christophe horn says it's design
is fresh and new yet classic and people
love that at Mercedes they think that
the sea classes interior design is the
best in its segment segment and
obviously many of the jury thought the
same thing
the CH show car vision vente vente
normally concept cars like this are made
to look at but aren't suitable to drive
our test driver Montes kirat says today
is the exception because he'll be taking
the vision vente vente for a spin the
bent event a is the Spanish
manufacturers first SUV influenced model
it's designed to be both practical and
elegant um not just starts the car with
a push of a button welcome Matias today
you have scheduled to go to the circuit
your best luck here is six minutes and
18 seconds car is ready and weather
conditions are favorable sehr schon yep
he's pleasantly surprised to hear the
car call him by name even if it's the
wrong one but then Montes sounds like a
more common moniker so he's used to it
the personalized welcome is part of the
event event these futuristic service and
infotainment concept
let's hear list montes points out that
he doesn't expect a show car to perform
like a series production model the seats
in this prototype aren't well
upholstered and the suspension isn't
very well tuned yet the motor is loud
too but then say 'it's concept car is to
provide an idea of the future motoring
facialist album he can Mandy spiciest
demo dela that sucs enforced in the bent
event a makes a powerful impression with
a dynamically striking front end SIA is
especially proud of the Conner side
profile with its accentuated lines as
seen here in the outside mirror with its
20-inch wheels the vision vente vente
has its feet firmly on the ground the
wheel rims were designed specially for
the show car
the exteriors combination of sporty
dynamics and striking contours is
matched by the car's interior the
dominant materials leather aluminum
glass and glossy plastic are
high-quality and crafted with attention
to detail we wouldn't expect anything
less in a concept car
backseat passengers can follow the
travel route on a display screen
as a zune matta says he was fascinated
by his test drive with a vision vente
vente ciothes impressive concept for its
future models he jokes that there is
something even more impressive an extra
that might come with a car this little
electric vehicle thingy it fits
perfectly in the trunk and is designed
so you don't even have to walk the last
few meters from your parking spot to
work the shopping center or poem for
that matter some einkaufen order in
swanson mitsuya clean as a familiar
stamatis begins to sum up his experience
but it's not over maybe a special
driver's license should be required for
this extra equipment montes at any rate
swears that in the future he'll restrict
himself to driving cars as all
especially miss an love a vital him else
out of fun
Bentley is revamping the Continental GT
series the new front bumper and a
smaller grill are among the new features
the fenders have also been redesigned
and now have vents the new top
performance GT Speed which comes with a
w12 engine is now even more powerful and
a little more economical with fuel
consumption of 14.1 litres per 100
kilometers Audi's new q7 aims to eject a
bit of oomph in the full-size SUV
segment the german automaker is the
first to offer a diesel hybrid model
Audi has combined they tried and tested
3.0 TDI engine with an electric engine
to put out a performance of 275
kilowatts and fuel consumption of just
one point seven liters of diesel per 100
kilometers the q7 s electric engine can
cover a distance of fifty six kilometers
often Zevon Phaedra does about this
driver I know Dyson / says the Subaru
Forester is in the same dish as the
hyundai santa fe this son's qashqai and
Toyotas rav4 but also as premium models
like the Audi q3 the mercedes-benz glk
and BMWs x3 so what's with Subaru es
quite simply Subaru is the world's
largest producer of all wheel drive cars
for example in the United States Subaru
sells more vehicles than Volkswagen does
reason enough to take a closer look at
the subaru forester it's in the same
league as the VW tiguan in 2015 subaru
is expanding the choice of engine and
transmission combinations for the
forester for the first time this SUV is
also available as a diesel with the
lineartronic continuously variable
automatic transmission in an uptick in
fog lights pilot says the interior of
the new forester has changed a lot the
cockpit feels modern and the navigation
system with its piano black finish looks
sick and functions much better than in
the predecessor the lineartronic
transmission is also new a gear ratio is
stepless and makes for smooth shifts
that wasn't the case in the predecessor
lose directional stability wasn't
perfect with a forester you can take a
leisurely cruise it's never pretended to
be a race car
cbt stands for continuously variable
transmission initially this lineartronic
transmission was available only in
combination with gasoline engines but
the high torque lineartronic system
developed by the schaeffler company has
made it possible to apply this efficient
and comfortable transmission concept to
the higher torque produced by the diesel
boxer engine optically the Forester
radiates power but the design also
signals the cars high level of comfort
the gentle curve of the front windows
results in a flowing silhouette nothing
in the cars 4.6 meter length offends the
eye
under the hood is the 2.0 litre diesel
boxer engine boxer engines are
characterized by the low level of
vibration they transmit to the interior
our test car generates 108 kilowatts and
consumed six point three liters of fuel
for 100 kilometers the sport version
with lineartronic costs just over 40,000
euros in Germany
the interior is built for comfort that
goes for the seats and front or back
there is ample legroom the trunk holds a
respectable 505 liters of cargo the back
seats can be folded down separately
using a lever that expands the storage
space to 1577 leaders as a bubble for
Assad final says Subaru worked hard on
redesigning the new Forester which is
still the best in its class off road
earlier problems with the sat-nav and
the interior have been solved both are
now state-of-the-art no other model of
this segment has a boxer diesel even at
low revs the subaru forester has power
to burn and is fun to drive no wonder
it's seen so often on mountain roads
even in the Alps enthusiasts
the thin CD these are the sporting puris
from the Porsche family it's GTS models
test driver Klaus needs of it says
there's a newcomer to the 911 series the
target GTS you might ask why well some
people want to car the differs from the
basic model one that's sporty-er more
powerful and the target GTS also has a
different suspension for better Road
handling and where's the best place to
test it on a racetrack and that's where
Klaus is on the Ascari racetrack in
southern Spain in Dutch ponyo of the
identity escali as for a former racing
driver Klaus is eager to test the GTS
and the Sport Plus version with the
electronic stability system turned off
he takes the target top model to its
limits
the mole door closes first impressions
the engine has real bite 430 horsepower
no one needs that much but here on a
racetrack it enables him to drive very
fast laps Klaus has the engine response
as soon as you press the gas pedal the
car takes off like a rocket that's how
they teach now let's get up the target
GTS has a six-cylinder 316 kilowatt
boxer engine that launches it from 0 to
100 kilometers an hour and 4.3 seconds
hard to top but power like that calls
for a suspension to match the phobic
hissing Wow says the chassis is a
centimeter closer to the road than the
standard target enabling it to take
curves faster the cars aerodynamics hope
it hug the road a higher rear spoiler
also helps it take curves faster and
that's what Klaus will do now
god I come the rear swings out of it
says Klaus back what fun
as far as the target GTS is design goes
Porsche knows exactly what pleases
sports car fans like matte black 20-inch
wheel rims with central locking the roll
bar is a target trademark
the steering wheel synthetic suede
finish pampers the drivers hands and in
its GTS models Porsche provides a treat
for sports car fans ears
yuppers merla porsche engineer says the
target GTS has a choice events for the
exhaust including one that's unraveled
that goose engine performance but also
adds to the sound
guns in chardon avi our vehicle tester
likes that you can drive this target
with the roof down though you sit in a
relatively enclosed cockpit you feel the
wind and the speed it's really fun to
drive very sporty but quite a smooth
ride it's very quick and feels very
positive thanks to the four-wheel drive
he says and always have enough power
coming out of the bend and the 430
horsepower engine gives it plenty of um
Klaus is now going to do a country road
test after all he says that's where most
people will be driving their target GTS
and Tyga get this will tell the
excitement luckily there are some
picturesque country roads in southern
Spain and what could be better than to
be travelling along and a convertible
when the weather is fine the targa is
also more comfortable than most of the
911 series and dynamic to boot
align the smooth want guns claffey Wow
says the target is a really nice
convertible that's also suitable for
everyday use his conclusion this target
GTS is a perfect card both in terms of
performance on the racing track and for
taking it easy on country roads the 137
thousand euro price tag however does put
him off a bit and also means that the
pleasure will remain reserved for the
select few money think about zoofilia
combination in the nose this out of here
to Elliott so lean back and enjoy you
can always dream that you're taking the
target GTS out for a spin
it's like something from a
science-fiction film and yet it really
exists the legendary mercedes-benz c 111
most young people are surprised to find
out how old it is 46 positively
middle-aged for car buffs on the wrong
side of 50 it brings back childhood
memories the c 111 featured in a card
game and it was also available as a
battery-powered model car
it's a pity that it never made it out
onto the road it's become koalas
experiment as Michelle bulk head of
mercedes-benz classic explains it was
presented as an experimental vehicle and
that's what it remained back then they
wanted to test whether it was possible
to see really produce a vehicle with a
fiberglass chassis and produce a small
production run for the US market but
that idea didn't last long as a lot to
show them from to screw Mercedes
engineers continued to develop their
baby far beyond the concept car stage it
made its first appearance at the
frankfurt international motor show in
1969 the car broke new ground in terms
of both engineering and design the first
model included a 280 horsepower 3 rotor
Wankel engine with top speeds of 270
kilometers an hour
in 1970 Mercedes presented a thoroughly
revised version of the c 111 with a 4
rotor 350 horsepower Wankel engine the
two-seater could accelerate from
standstill to 100 km/h in 4.9 seconds
but there were a number of arguments
against launching a series production
the Wankel engine was a gas guzzler with
little torque and it wasn't reliable or
durable enough to meet the carmaker
standards yet there was no question of
terminating the c 111 project the
engineers and designers had put their
hearts and souls into it many were keen
to reinvent Mercedes and they were
enthusiastic about the motorsport
technology in the rear suspension where
the wheels boasted three wishbones and
two trailing arms motorsport I'll
initial block of mercedes-benz classic
says that the Mercedes motorsport
department which had achieved
outstanding successes in the 1930s and
had in principle won the Formula One
World Championships twice in the 1950s
together with fond Xia still existed in
rd and they were driven by the desire to
build sports cars alongside the sedans
and station wagons and they engaged with
this topic with a knowledge of
subsequent developments in the field he
says they constructed this vehicle with
the help of computers with the aim of
using as few aerodynamic aids as
possible the shape of the chassis alone
should be enough and they were extremely
successful on the CC knows house hunt
along
a sports car with no spoilers that's
pretty unusual Mercedes achieve the
necessary aerodynamic qualities with the
cars streamlined wedge-shaped design
but it was the vehicles head-turning
chassis that was another main obstacle
to mass production it was made of
fiberglass reinforced plastic and at
that time the material couldn't provide
sufficient stability it also didn't meet
contemporary safety standards crumple
zones were out of the question plastic
doesn't buckle it snaps despite its
impressive performance and appearance
the Wankel engine and reinforced plastic
chassis meant that the writing was on
the wall for the c 111 its wedge design
seemed almost revolutionary for the
rather conservative Mercedes brand and
helped give the company a facelift
the car might have looked completely new
on the outside but in the inside it's
scream Mercedes nothing here seems to
have been designed specially for the c
111
in all likelihood the horizontally
fitted radio arose from necessity rather
than by design the cockpit was pretty
cramped and this c 111 there's no rotor
driven Wankel engine nor any piston
driven diesel engine
in 1970 Mercedes installed gasoline
engines in two cars
their performance data might not be as
impressive as the earlier models but
it's still easy to understand the lure
of the c 111 in fact allegedly mercedes
was sent blank checks in the post after
they presented the car at the iaa in
frankfurt and a few months later at the
geneva motor show more than a dozen
versions of the c 111 were built but
none of them were ever put up for sale
they stand in Mercedes own Museum and no
doubt in some secret garages somewhere
there is no market for these cars and
they're probably never will be this c
111 like all the rest is unique a
one-off its value hard to say priceless
certainly it must be worth at least
several million euros